فاتورة ، ما مدى تفاؤلك في أن
ما نراه مع اللقاحات والذي من
الواضح أنه أخبار جيدة جدًا ، فالنتائج
التي تعرف أنها ستأتي عند 95
بينما حتى 70 75 فعالية كانت ستكون
جيدة ،
هل تعتقد أن هذا سيكون
مؤشرًا على اللقاحات الأخرى
هل سيبحثون جميعًا كما تعلم ،
هل سنفاجأ من
الجانب الإيجابي مع كل هذه الأشياء ، نعم ، ستعمل جميع اللقاحات تقريبًا ومع مستويات الفعالية العالية جدًا ،
كان لقاح فايزر في منتصف العبوة من حيث
الأجسام المضادة  طلبت
astrazeneca الذي نأمل على الأقل أن توافق عليه المملكة المتحدة
قبل نهاية العام
، كان أقل قليلاً من ذلك
آه
نوفافاكس جونسون وجونسون آه أنت تعرف
أفضل أه مناعة أه من هؤلاء ، لذلك
لدينا الآن أه بعض من  المصانع
في الهند التي تصنع لقاح أسترازينيكا
معرضة للخطر ، كما تعلم ، لقد قمنا بتمويل هذا
النقل وهذه المصانع كبيرة الحجم
جدًا وتلك اللقاحات رخيصة
جدًا وقابلة للتطوير ، لذا أه القليل من التطبيقات القليلة التالية
Provals uh astrazeneca novavax and johnson
johnson سيكونان حاسمين
للوصول إلى أرقام كبيرة جدًا أه
لكنني متفائل
أنه بحلول فبراير أه من المحتمل جدًا أن
يثبتوا جميعًا أنهم
فعالون وآمنون جدًا ومدى قلقك بشأن
تنفيذ  جزء التسليم من هذا ،
أعني
أن الأولين يتطلبان الاحتفاظ بهما
في درجات حرارة منخفضة
وجرعات مضاعفة ، بينما الآخرون ليسوا كذلك ،
لكن بالنظر إلى الأمر برمته ، فإن
توزيع اللقاحات سيكون
مشكلة كبيرة أو هل تعتقد  يمكن
إدارته ،
نعم ، هناك بمجرد أن تحصل على
أه يزداد العرض بدرجة كافية ، ثم
يكون لديك كل من اللوجيستيات
والاستعداد لأخذ
اللقاح وأنا آمل
أه على الرغم من أن القطعة اللوجستية
مرتبكة بعض الشيء في الولايات المتحدة الآن  هناك
يجب أن يكون موقعًا على شبكة الإنترنت
حيث تكون بالفعل
أه تشير إلى حالتك
ومعايير ترتيب الأشخاص ، يتم
إخبارك بأن رمز الأولوية الخاص بك
يعتمد على مهنتك وعمرك
أه تعلم أنه يجب على الأشخاص  ترى
أنك تريد أن تتأكد من أنك لا
تضيع أيًا من هذا اللقاح
ولكنك تعلم
بطريقة غير كاملة إلى حد
ما أعتقد أن الخدمات اللوجستية سيتم حلها ،
أعتقد أنه سيكون هناك عدد كافٍ من
الأشخاص الذين
يقفزون  في وقت مبكر ، يرى الناس المزيد
من الأدلة على السلامة وأنه بمرور
الوقت سنصل
إلى مستوى 70 في المائة الإضافي
الذي نحتاجه من أجل إيقاف أه
انتشار
المرض أعلم أنك لا تحب التحدث عن
السياسة ولكن
كما  الكثير من الناس يستمعون إليك
وكمواطن هل أنت قلق
بشأن ما يجري الآن
معك أعلم أعني
أه حالة يبدو فيها الرئيس
مصمماً على عدم
أه عدم التنازل أه
عن الانتخابات الآن أنت تعلم أنا
قيل دائمًا أن الناس لا يحبون
الخاسرين المؤلمين وهناك الكثير على المحك
من حيث
مدى جودة ديمقراطيتنا أه تسمح
بالانتقال السلمي أه تعلمون لذلك آمل
أن يتم
بسرعة كبيرة أه
جهود الانتقال
أه تم تفعيلها بالكامل أه
أنت  أعلم أنني لا أتبع  تفاصيل دقيقة
ولكن
آه من المخيب للآمال أن حالات
عدم اليقين
تنشأ حيث لا يجب أن
يكون هناك شيء
ولكنك متفائل بأنه
سيتم حل هذا الأمر ، كما تعلمون بعبارة أخرى ، ما
مدى قلقك بشأن المكان الذي نحن فيه
الآن.
فكرة أن هناك
ضررًا طويل المدى لإخبار
الأشخاص الذين يثقون بك
أن نظامنا الانتخابي
معيب
أه أنت تعلم أنني أعلم أن هناك الكثير من
القلق بشأن ذلك ولكن أعتقد أننا
سننتقل بسلاسة إلى
الرئيس-  انتخب
بايدن لديك بعض الخبرة في
نظريات المؤامرة
أه هل تقلق من أن نظرية المؤامرة هذه
ستعرف أن
هذا قد تم
إطلاقه الآن المؤامرة حول
انتخابات مزورة
بشكل جيد أعتقد أنه يجب علينا أن
نفخر بالمثال الذي جلسنا فيه عادةً
وإخبار البلدان الأخرى التي تعرفها أن
لديها انتخابات حرة ونزيهة
وأن الخاسر يحتاج إلى
أه تنازل ولا تعرف ، حاول
تغيير القواعد أو الالتفاف على القواعد
بطريقة ما ، لذلك نحن  هو نور ساطع
أه لدول أخرى في بعض الأحيان لا
نرتقي إلى ذلك
ولكن في معظم الأحيان نقوم بذلك